[Music]
i've known pete dinklage for a long time
pete is uh married to a college friend
of mine many people know him on game of
thrones but this was pre-game of thrones
i ran into pete at an ungodly hour at
jfk at the airport so i hadn't slept i
was like cracked out looking and
we were both really hungry
and we got egg mcmuffins at mcdonald's
this is not an ad we just we're kind of
sitting in silence eating these egg
mcmuffins this guy came up to us and he
goes
uh hey guys uh
sorry to interrupt just want to say uh
thanks for the laughs
and he walked away
pete and i just kept eating for a few
seconds and then i forget which one of
us said it but
we thought well wouldn't it be funny if
the guy didn't recognize us as actors
and he just had been on the phone with
his like former frank buddy and he was
like dude you'll never believe what i'm
looking at
this like scrawny pasty nerd and this
like little person are shoving egg
mcmuffins to their mouths in silence but
see i think a guy who just found that
funny wouldn't be polite enough to come
up and say something to you that's true
unless you're not telling the whole
story and you were like baby birding egg
mcmuffins into pete's mouth
you're like oh i forgot to mention i was
uh oh yeah just putting little pieces of
egg mcmuffin into pizza
you're listening to life is short no pun
intended i'm your host justin long life
could be
[Music]
and with me as always is my slightly
taller brother
christian am i slightly taller i think
so haven't we gone back to back and
determine fake debate
and determine that
uh i think we're almost exactly the same
height actually oh well you have
scoliosis too so i think if it weren't
for the scoliosis oh i tower above you
i'm
and now if mcdonald's is listening
i would love to see that ad yeah that's
true i don't think pete would
do it i don't think but if he did i know
he wouldn't do it i know you would do it
i love egg mcmuffins i love pete
yeah you weren't there that morning but
it was really funny i think it was pete
who said and pete's got a really good
sense of humor about that about being a
little person yeah yeah the fact that he
referenced it but see i think someone
like pete
it makes sense that he would be able to
laugh at himself i i don't think you
could be a little person and get to
where he's gotten without having the
ability to like kind of laugh at himself
but
the reason we're talking about it pete
dinklage is
i mean now he's a household name and
everyone recognizes him from game of
thrones but
even then
because he was a little person in
hollywood and there aren't many of them
i'm sure he's always been since he
started acting he's been someone that
it's very clear how you know him you
know you don't say
what were you in like
right where have i seen you before um
it's a defining factor it's like very
much so but our guest today is someone
who
has been working for
20 years in
countless movies and tv shows and
uh everyone knows her but she's the kind
of person that it's it's difficult to
pinpoint
how they know yeah she's the ultimate
like where do i know you from like i
know you and i and i get versions of
that we've talked to other people on the
show other actors who
get versions of that but i think she is
like the quintessential where do i know
you from actress um our guest today is
judy greer and part of what makes her so
special is that such a talented actress
is that she she blends into these
different worlds so well
that she kind of i i don't think she's
defined she can't be defined by any one
thing and she's in so many things to the
point where she wrote a book a few years
ago called i don't know what you know me
from
because
she says she's constantly getting that
you know and i think you get a version
of that um too
uh i got it yesterday at the pet store
um
uh somebody the guy was like and i i now
what were you doing at the pet store
well
i was buying
goldfish for my new
indoor garden
and i realized that i had made a mistake
the last time i went there and gotten
the fan tail goldfish the fancy like 299
apiece goldfish and this time i realized
there was 20 cents
goldfish 20 cent a piece called more
disposable well yeah and i have a little
snapping turtle in the uh in the
environment so pete is not listening
well i don't think peter would would
peter mine that
goldfish being eaten by a snapping
turtle it's natural
not when you force force the goldfish
into this uh dangerous environment yeah
i don't know i i don't know if peter
would care well if
like if you're a member of peta uh
please write in and let us know if that
is a thing that i shouldn't be talking
about or doing
i'll continue to do it but i just won't
talk about it if it's frowned upon so
the guy reckons anyway the guy yeah
so back to my story about getting
recognized
i realized that when you guys were
talking about it so i think you and judy
greer are anyway actually yeah yeah
sorry so what did how did what well i
just said i said what do i know he said
but you're an act i said yeah i'm an
actor and he said well where do i and i
i never know what to say to people
because i've done
and it sounds braggy it just sounds like
inherently douchey to be like well i've
done a lot of things and i don't know
what you saw you know but i but that's
the truth is i don't know what
people saw so i and it's also so i say
like well my name's justin my last
name's long uh and and again this out of
context sounds really douchy if i'm like
just google
it's easier if you google it i know that
does sound too but i think that will
sound less douchey
uh the longer yeah the longer google's
around because now it's like people
people would do that anyway people do do
that yeah and then i see people like
when we're out at dinner or something i
see people at tables next to us if you
glance over you see people i do and i
see my face on their screen and like and
they're like uh and then but then
there's that moment of like oh yeah i
can see them from like a couple feet
away going like ah and then they turn
the camera yeah and they angle the
camera yeah that's really obnoxious but
um where did you meet judy greer so uh
judy and i i want to see you never
really worked with her right i did wait
were you baiting me yeah
you get this little like
glimmer in your eye this little
mischievous like
glint in the eye um
a judy but i had i think i had met judy
before i don't know my memory's so bad
um but i we worked together on one of
the uh apple mac commercials uh i'm a
mac pc
iconic what do you call those iconic mac
no i think
that commercials apple commercials mac
versus pc mac versus pc yeah she played
a
yogi who um was trying to calm
i think she was like trying to calm pc
down i don't know i was i was excited to
work with her because i had been a fan
of her hers and um earlier in her career
she often played
like best friend roles yes like kind of
ditzy how would you describe those um
kind of flighty
yeah yeah um like jawbreaker
13 going on 30 20 something drops you're
not really gonna date him are you yeah
and like no we don't get along and
she's the one that like sees that her
friend and the the co-worker that she
doesn't get along with have like
chemistry before the friends
that'll trope yeah but now she's in
bigger movies she she was in uh the
planet of the apes franchise and ant-man
or as justin calls it ant-man ant-man
yeah uh and she's that doesn't get old
that joke no it's always funny
and now she's on the show kidding uh jim
carrey that's on show time so she works
wait are you you're not are you kidding
i'm not i'm just joe not joking oh uh
she works all the time and she's in big
things and she uh she's somebody that
you probably know
that you might you might not know her
name even yeah right but you definitely
have seen something she's in probably
many things
yeah
and she was nice enough to sit down with
justin and
and
like i said they didn't they only worked
together once so they didn't really know
each other well but um
i think you'll see that they uh seemed
like they knew each other yeah we were
like kindred spirits yeah you don't hear
that phrase a lot no yeah so uh check
out uh checkout so here is my
talk with my with my kindred spirit your
new friend yeah the ubiquitous and very
sweet judy greer life could be a dream
sweetheart
so your mother
was a nun for eight years yeah um my dad
was in the seminary for seven years
really yes so i think did he marry jesus
he divorced jesus they separated and
then they got back together oh is he now
he's not a priest but he's very they're
very devout still catholic catholic are
yours not anymore catholic no they left
the catholic church when i was like 10
or 11
because i left the catholic church when
i was 10 or 11. wow so they why
well there were cuter boys who went to
presbyterian church and carol smith uh
went to presbyterian church and so
you're preaching to the choir
so i was like
if i go to church can i just go to like
any church i want because that was the
rule like you have to go to church so i
went to presbyterian church with carol
smith and i started singing in the choir
with her because the boys were cuter and
catholic church was weird and creepy and
boring and uh so my parents started
going to mass on saturday night because
you have to go to mass but then going to
like service
the presbyterian church to watch me sing
in the choir on sunday morning
and then the way they describe it is
they felt closer to god at the
presbyterian church so they eventually
left the catholic church completely but
yes
my mother did take her vow and i like to
remind her that my father is not her
first husband that he is her second
husband and she really does not like
that she doesn't think it's funny but i
do
she always says she gave her best years
to the lord which i say is you really
mean your [ __ ] years yeah you know
i think that about my dad i i've never
ascribed the word [ __ ] to it but but
it is yeah his [ __ ] years away [ __ ]
too that's true uh everyone listening
all the oh my male [ __ ] out there
uh 18 to 25 though he was yeah what was
oh no she was high school and the four
years after so whatever that is like 14
to 22 something like that she was in a
convent throughout high school she went
to high school in the convent
yeah it was high school and then the
four years after and then she got asked
to leave the convent they said she was
too wild
what what constitutes being too wild uh
i think she's not telling me some things
because her reasons are like i wore a
red bathing suit i was like really cause
stuff comes up like all the time that
i'm like whoa what and then she's like
tell me that
yeah and then like later like a year
later i'm like remember when you told me
that thing she's like oh that's not true
and i'm like okay i'm super confused
i use the term duplicitous to describe
my mother i don't know it's we all have
our own weird like survival mechanisms
so for her were her parents very devout
yes in fact
why she told me she went to bnn was
because of um her older sister like ran
off got pregnant and like ran off and
got married and broke
my grandmother's heart my mother's
mother's heart and so she was like i'll
go be a nun and that'll make her feel
better oh god she's is she a real
pleaser i mean is she still like that uh
i mean are we gonna talk about my mom no
no no we don't have jim
no it's okay yes she is and she's also a
martyr she's all the time yeah yeah yeah
was she were they excited that you
wanted to be an actress no they weren't
like thrilled but they were super
supportive yeah you know what i mean it
took a long time for them to stop asking
me to like get a master's degree in
something yes or to stop like my mom
always was like why don't you become
a manicurist and then you could do nails
when you're not acting i'm like that's
still a hustle in la like i don't think
she really like understood she wanted
but she wanted something more practical
yes my parents always did i feel like
that's working yeah yeah yeah unless
you're raised by artists themselves
right i don't know my parents are not so
you know it's funny my mom was is an
actress and she was of my two parents
the
by far the the less encouraging
that i could see that yeah because she's
probably like oh so awful totally and i
i know and it is hard i think
um
and then to think of seeing your kids
being like rejected so much of course
that would be awful what did they do
your parents
my mother was a hospital administrator
forever and my dad was an engineer he
worked at ford motor company okay why we
lived in detroit detroit
and and that was when detroit was
thriving right
now
ish yeah the car companies were still
like that was the main industry in
detroit at the time still when i was a
kid but like
i think it was the beginning of
you know what happened they called the
white flight where everyone like moved
out to the suburbs and then like
um are they still there your parents no
they live in ohio now
so no and i uh sorry to anyone who's
from ohio but if anyone's like they are
white my husband they took flight well
so
but they didn't fly to ohio okay they
just went to a supper your husband's
from where my husband's from here but
he's always like making a joke he'll say
sometimes like well because you're from
ohio and i'm like don't you ever [ __ ]
say i'm from ohio
i'm from michigan
and your michigan accent comes out as
you defend yourself
your husband is an executive producer on
bill maher yeah so cool i i love him
when did you first start acting were you
in high school were you actually staying
in the choir
i did i was i'm a terrible singer um i
started acting in high school
um because i was a
dancer a ballet dancer and
and then
i was sort of like mediocre at that and
i thought like
that in high school
yes well i started dancing and i danced
for a really long time and like as you
get older you know you really it's
that's one of those things where
you can't fake it like you're a really
good ballet dancer you're not and you
had a sense that you weren't but you
yeah i mean you can tell i didn't love
it because it was so uh frustrating to
not like be getting better like you get
to a certain point and like these girls
are just like incredible and and also to
be honest like i didn't want to devote
all of my time to it like that's what
you have to do you have to and you have
to just
like to be that i always got frustrated
when i would hear when i was younger
like you can be anything you want to be
because i'd be like no you actually
can't
by the way don't tell your kids that
because you cannot be anything you want
that's true so like there are
limitations people have limitations i'm
all for inspirational quotes but like
let's be realistic um
but i i also didn't have a ton of
friends in high school because of ballet
because that was like a whole separate
thing so i got to a point where i was
like well i can
kind of get i can continue down this
road where i'll for sure like be poor
and never have like a job as a ballet
dancer
or i could maybe like try to have some
friends in high school and have like a
fun high school life so
i did that so that was that got me into
acting which was just like auditioning
musicals yeah i didn't have a ton of
be in the for
friends and i wanted to have a lot of
friends and so there's so many parallels
between that's exactly why i started
really yeah girls just to hang out with
oh yeah i was too small to play sports i
love football but i was like four foot
ten that seems unlikely that you were
four foot ten going into high school
four four ten eighty nine pounds you
could have gotten a scholarship to
college if you hadn't grown i think
that's true to be a just a student
like you could have
oh i think you get to be a football
player oh no like just to be a
freakishly small
yeah they would have just to be a mascot
for the for the michigan they're one of
those things though it's like you can be
anything you want yeah like no you can't
you can't that's true you can't be a
football player if you're four foot ten
that's true yeah you all saw the movie
lucas although probably not because yeah
i love lucas i love terry green and um i
i i of course identified with that kid
because he so badly wanted to and that
was me um but it's true we we
and especially now
i think it was different when when we
were grown now it's i can't even imagine
yeah yeah but then but there are do you
encounter that i'm sorry no go ahead i
do encounter that with with actors
sometimes i i see younger actors who
really want it who doesn't want to do it
and they
i i how do you say to somebody well you
just don't
i don't you're not you don't have
i don't know because i
with acting it's
it's funny because i think what what
makes you better and better is more life
experience and so
i can meet a young actor and think like
you know some people just have these
like natural abilities so that aside
right like i think as you get older you
travel more you have more relationships
with people like you just become like a
generally more interesting person you
become a better actor well i think you
become more comfortable with yourself
too yeah maybe yeah and like and so i
don't know with younger actors it's hard
to say like i'm always afraid to say
like
maybe this isn't your thing
because
um it could be but i always just tell
people like whenever people ask me
advice i always say like go to ucb or
groundlings and take classes there and
like have some fun and make friends yeah
exactly and make some connections and
that's and why not i mean that's how you
started that's how i started telling
people
it's as simple as that just go and take
some classes in la and like have a life
outside of your work like have some
hobbies have some friends travel what do
you do to get outside of that bubble
because i i've i don't do anything were
you right you definitely i write you
don't cook
i've been baking oh that's been
interesting um what what started that
well i did this a movie i did a movie
and my makeup artist monica on the movie
i did
she bakes bread and had a starter and so
she was gonna give me her starter and
she was like it's so easy so then i was
like i could do this and then it wasn't
it was terrible so i kind of
then was not gonna get frustrated so i
just bought like a bread for beginners
book and i started from the beginning so
i've just been making basically yeah
what were you doing what this movie
called
playing with fire
it's a john cena vehicle who by the way
is one of my new favorite people in the
entire world he is the greatest oh yeah
that's cool and he's very funny
he's so funny yeah he's really funny and
he's a really hard worker
and
uh it's hard to get past his mo he's
massive though right is he as big as he
is this really funny thing happened
there's this like stupid moment of
course our characters are like fighting
but really like we end up together oh
spoiler alert
um so there's a scene where like we're
he's like covered in schmutz and like
we're fighting and he goes around the
corner to like change his shirt but
there's a mirror
so i'm like you know and then another
thing that i can see the reflection the
mirror of his character so and then my
character is like oh but she's like
still talking so when we were shooting
the scene on the first take he like took
his shirt off and i saw in the mirror
and i just was like
and i couldn't even speak and i was like
i'm so sorry
i
was like i can't i can't remember my
life i have to say for the audience
the listening audience those that are
still listening you're like
flushed i know you know i'm sitting
girls from judy anything like that in
person i was like ah
you just turned the color of your
mother's bikini when she got kicked out
of the
bikini i was like that's how i felt in
the moment and then there was like this
huge laugh from the monitor video
village because everyone was like oh can
you imagine and i'll never know what
this is like but having a physique that
takes people's breath away it took my
lines away my breath away and like it
still is having that effect no it was
just the funny just the memory of it but
also like i sort of pride myself on like
not being that kind of girl like i'm
like i like a brain i like funny like
little braun is fine like he's all those
things which is what i love about him
but like i don't think of myself as
being someone who's going to be like
stopped in her tracks by like him taking
his shirt off and then i was like
it was really funny he has all the
muscles like all the muscles on the
chart you have muscles that he has
muscles that like aren't
on people yes it's true and he's really
funny about like before his coffee and
he's very particular about like when he
has his coffee and there's a very big
difference between like pre coffee
jc and like post coffee jc and really
enjoy the hulk
he's just like really more like we're
gonna attack this day we're gonna like
get this day we are gonna and it's like
really i think he's doing it to make me
laugh but it's very wrestling it's very
like pro wrestling yeah you can see that
side of him but then like also
um he had to uh play
he was learning to play the piano
and during some setup like he was just
in the corner like playing the piano and
he was playing
he did learn just because oh he's like
super into learning [ __ ] like he teaches
himself stuff all the time um and he was
learning piano
and you could hear him practicing in his
trailer on like his little synthesizer
but he was playing on set one day like
he was playing a pixie song where is my
mind and i was like
is that where is my mind and he was like
you knew what song it was you could tell
what song it was i was like yeah it's
the pixie song where's my mind right
isn't that it he's like yeah he was just
like so who are the pixies i thought i
wrote that
god damn it then he turns into
pre-coffee
you know what happened once i did a
movie with billy joe armstrong and he on
set was playing he was like playing one
of his songs on the guitar uh just like
a acoustic guitar and i like shazamed it
for fun and like a whole other song came
up and he was like oh [ __ ]
that was really funny
that you had the time of your life
our listeners will know that my
tangential relationship to billy cho was
that he gave me a tattoo once that that
has since faded to the point of
no longer there's no ink left in it but
yeah that happens
i guess so yeah if they if you don't go
deep enough with the with the needle i
just got my first tattoo ever no kidding
yeah isn't that cute i want to capture
my reaction on the microphone can you
even see it yes it's a um it's a star
it's a little it's a circle and inside
is a four
point star tell your listeners exactly
what it is
you know you know what don't
they don't care moving on
we've done enough tattoo talk no what it
what is it um it's okay this is where i
get really nerdy um
this is where i know i know uh it's the
window it's caesar's window
from
rise of the planet of the apes
which then became like
like a motif in dawn of the planet of
the apes which i was in and also war of
the planet of the apes um
well i have seen them all and uh i will
i will take your nerd card and pick it
on up um
that's really cool i also must have been
to commemorate an experience that was
probably a huge part of your life
incredible yeah and my husband got a
matching one so we dorked out
so cool did you like were you a planning
the apes nerd before you did no he was
he is he loved it so much and so when
ryze came out
i was like it's cool i can probably get
us tickets to the premiere so i know
james franco
i didn't actually but i knew tyler um
tyler levine who was in it
yeah so tyler got his tickets
so um
so we went to the premiere and he my
husband just geeked out completely and
was like you know i mean they're gonna
make another one i was like oh yeah i
guess they would he's like you have to
be in it you have to be in it you have
to be in it so i'm like okay rise of the
planet was the first one right first
yeah with james franco and john lithgow
and tyler levine and
other people and then um a bunch of
monkeys andy circus all right andy
circus um who i think should have been
nominated he should do all of his
performances he should do more motion
capture work
does anyone even know what he looks like
um he was a bad guy in something
recently in black panther right he was
yes he had really cool mutton chops i
think so good so i met him 100 years ago
on a movie called 13 going on 30. he
played
our boss uh jennifer garner and i worked
for a magazine together and andy circus
was our boss
oh yes that's right yeah that was the
first time i met him so he hooked you up
with the tickets um
tyler did oh yeah yeah and we went and
dean that's husband he was like you have
to be in the next one so i called my
agent and i was like let me make another
one
like is there anything and then he said
like well there's one female role but
carrie russell's already playing it i
was like oh sorry i wasn't specific i
want to be an eight like can i be an ape
in it and they're like uh yes of course
but i still had to audition so i
auditioned you're like not an orangutang
or a [ __ ] gibbon no no
i'm gonna be an ape um i auditioned with
an acting scene what's that audition
like that audition was regs audition
like they gave me a scene of carries
like just to act like i just acted but
then i got to the next level which was
the craziest audition of my life which
was where i had to go and work out with
the guys who were being apes i had to
like drive out terry notary is like the
ape genius and he trains all the guys
who play apes
he's an amazing person and he so i had
to go out and like and like basically
work out with the stunt guys and like he
videotaped it it's not a videotape if
it's on an iphone is it it's just
recording
i would call it a video so he videotaped
me like pretending to be an ape with
like cirque du soleil guys and parkour
guys
who have since become friends of mine at
the time i felt like such an ass i i but
you probably it's you probably feel like
less of an ass when you're surrounded by
other people doing that that's true
at the time i was really nervous i was
less i less i felt less bad or scared or
like self-conscious when i was actually
on set and then the guys were like okay
this is what you do and then they would
like help me but at the time
i was just like oh my gosh so it's like
learning like dance moves kind of kind
of yeah it's like it's like the stuff we
did in theater school that you're like
yes am i ever
going to be a tiger like i'm never going
to play a tiger this is so stupid guess
what you might be a tiger
yeah yeah you might be an ape yeah and
and if you aspire to be an ape yeah you
know that's a yeah you can do anything
right
thanks let's erase the beginning of this
if i guess you can do anything
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
we'll meet again
we also started around the same time i
think you were you went to depaul yeah
and and studied acting there
did you only want to do theater at the
time would do or did you have
aspirations to be in movies and to do i
didn't know what i wanted to do i never
thought i would be an actor i just kept
going there
huh because it
was where i went huh
did you enjoy acting at that was there a
point where you were like this is what i
have to do it took a long time it wasn't
until like a few years i think into my
career couple months ago
yeah
it just always seemed like
crazy that this was even happening so as
i was like this is gonna run out like
i'm gonna stop getting jobs and then
i'll go back to school and like do a
thing so you don't have any like
delusions of grandchildren like this
yeah this is the next that's just gonna
keep going up no i never did um i still
don't i don't think that the job i'm
currently doing will be my last oh
that's fine i heard mike myers say that
in an interview once and it made me feel
really it was really comforting i mean
yeah that that he just assumes and i'm
the same way yeah like i'm always like
oh this will be it's a nice way to go it
was great it was great um had a good run
and then yeah well you yeah i mean if
that happens you had a hell of a run
and and
and this is somebody who three days out
of school got you got your first movie i
know
that's why it seems so unreal
it was just so unreal so it just became
that like i got this job
and then i did a play in chicago
where uh at the court theater
then like there was a show called early
edition which shot in chicago with kyle
chandler and um and like that was kind
of chicago's law order like if you were
an actor like you did an episode of
early edition kyle chandler was the star
yeah
fisher stevens oh my god
and another actress who i'm an ass and i
forgot her name and
um kate blanchett it was not what's her
name meryl something
um no
stress stress like stress throat
um so is kyle chandler even hunkier then
or less has he gotten hunky or more
hunky how can you get hunkier than yours
i don't know he's pretty hunky good lord
i know
um i did that and then i came out here
and then
i came out here for the premiere of that
movie for of kissing a photo yeah
and it was pilot season which i didn't
know what that was
but
you know someone was like well you
should stay for a couple weeks and
audition for tv pilots and so i did and
i got a movie and i got a jawbreaker
yes yes i know lisa sarah katzman and
lisa beach
who i love as well they've been oh yeah
do you find this that you have a few
there are a few i feel like champions
champions
ninety percent of casting directors like
won't even see me but like the ten
percent
well that's how it feels sometimes but
then there's like the lisa beaches and
like dab aquila there are a few who i'm
like yeah i think i know god forbid
has always been like really she's always
brings me in even if it's not totally
right like but someone told me once um
sometimes casting directors will bring
you in even if you're not exactly right
a because obviously they love you but
also like
if you are a good auditioner like you
make them look good like you're bringing
in people who are prepared and who do a
good job maybe like change the way the
director sees the character a little bit
maybe it's not you but maybe you've
opened up his mind or her mind to
thinking like oh it could be oh it could
be actually a little younger it could be
a little more quirky or it could be a
little bit more like whatever um
yeah they they they bring you into cup
which is kind of a compliment yeah which
is fine with me because honestly like i
never minded auditioning i always loved
it because i always liked the
opportunity like i like acting so i like
i like acting so when i get to audition
i guess i get to act and that's kind of
fun that's true also like what else am i
gonna do like with my day that's well
what would you do i mean work out in one
other thing
that's about what you think well now you
can pay
back and workout jawbreaker was uh that
was a late night there was
that's like i said that's when i started
out and and i think it was easier for me
to get an agent because
it was there was this big teen boom
around then like late 90s early 2000s of
american pie oh my gosh there was um it
was like
there was
so many and television shows and like i
know it was such a great time for us
because you got here and
that's how it felt it felt like well i
didn't get that one but like tomorrow i
have an audition for basically the same
movie right the sequel to that movie
yeah we'll be casting in a month right
um
you did a fair amount of those are you
cursed
i did cursed uh but i was so happy to
work with wes craven because before he
passed away yeah and it was like
i had never done a super like a real
like legit horror movie and i was like
oh you're going to do it like you're
going to do it with wes craven and rick
baker at the time oh was supposed to be
doing the werewolf even though
there was a situation that happened that
i don't really know a lot about okay
where that didn't happen can't wait to
dive into that
um so
he didn't end up doing the werewolf but
i did get one okay so they ended up
using like a cgi company to do the
werewolf transformation but what they'd
wanted to do was like this like american
werewolf in london with rick baker
werewolf transformation which i was a
werewolf
or where woman i don't know
there was a lot of times before i don't
know this is appropriate but there was a
lot of talk about boobs and about like
because they'd never done like a female
werewolf and they needed to like they
wanted to know there was all this
conversation about like how to make her
feminine but still like a werewolf like
how do we
like what's the difference between her
and him there was all this talk about
yeah basically how do we keep her
feminine looking like and still make it
like not a guy werewolf but a lady
werewolf and so
before rick baker quit i did get to do
one full makeup test like which was
so incredible
i did
with rick with rick and his assistant at
the time
um so i got to like do the full werewolf
makeup and it took so it took like six
hours and i brought in um this was back
when there were cds i brought in like a
david sedaris box set um of all of his
books and he was reading them all and
and they ended up having to like have me
shut it off because i was laughing too
hard and it was like [ __ ] with the
makeup and then we can't have them you
can't be laughing
yeah because i was like
you can't move your face like that
werewolf boobs i know
i didn't end up having werewolf foods
but they must have done some experiments
with the werewolf boobs there was like
drawings that i never really got to see
thankfully or not and uh and wouldn't
werewolves have
six
like teeth well it was just like how do
you wear teeth
how do you keep her i understood their
like conundrums yeah you want to keep
her feminine but like also anyway it
ended up being terrible have you ever
seen that footage
uh no i would love a picture of myself
as a werewolf so it was like really i
just remember staring i also played once
a bearded woman and like i just stared
at myself in the mirror
no it was in a tv show with jason
called my name is earl oh yeah yeah i
was a bearded woman in that and i just
remember staring at myself in the mirror
in my trailer like all during lunch just
like whoa
because i had long hair and i parted in
the middle and i looked like chris
robinson like i just felt like i was
like i was wearing these aviator
sunglasses yeah and then i was like i
look like chris robinson
it was really cool
and i was thinking like i kind of want
to like walk around like this yeah as
the kids say yeah trying to keep it hip
you are trying to keep this show really
uh appealing younger demographic had
someone else on no you're a very lit
guest
um do you ever think and i've seen you
do this now just in
since we've been talking you lose track
of all the things you've done who was
when was that uh yeah i don't know yeah
yeah i lose track of things but i can
get it back i just can't remember all of
it
all the time especially back things they
were doing so like it was seemed like
one after another you did what women
want and wedding planner and uh
small part which is something i've
always really loved doing coming in and
you know a couple days on a thing yeah
also by the time you get there they're
really happy for someone different on
set yeah and like yeah the bar is really
funny and so the lead actor is like a
huge diva yeah and they're just like
you're so great and like all you have to
do is just be on time and they're just
so thrilled yeah that you're not like
asking for something weird and
you're there what a breath of fresh air
i know she didn't demand a pumpkin spice
latte
yeah it's really i always like that i
always say my sweet spot is like
basically like three to seven on the
call sheet because yeah you get days off
you get to be really funny you are like
actually really supportive yeah you can
like do some heavy lifting if you need
to yeah three to seven three to seven
yeah that's why i like i feel like when
i go to places on location to shoot like
i get to actually like experience a city
that's true whereas like the that's true
stars of the movie yeah are like uh like
paul read i remember on ant-man when we
were in san francisco for a little chunk
of time yeah he was like saying like
people keep asking me like where i'm
eating and like what i'm doing and he's
like uh nothing because
i'm here every second and then take that
paul rudd i know you don't get to
experience cities no you don't get to
see san francisco haha what's it like to
be a big movie star who knew i saw all
the seals on the wharf
i went to alcatraz twice those were you
were like shrinking and growing and
shrinking and growing and being a hero
to millions of kids
uh you had you had that experience when
we worked together one time we worked
together we did a mac commercial
together and i was thinking about it
this morning because i was thinking how
funny it was that i played like a yogi
like i was like yeah like not a yogi
really i could see you i mean i've done
yoga i've certainly done loads of yoga i
mean i am an actress in hollywood you
don't get your sag card if you haven't
attended a yoga class you sweaty one at
that but um no i i just thought i was
thinking back on it thinking like god
like that's so funny that's so
interesting it was a funny one and it
was one that they
one of the few they ended up airing yeah
which really yeah we i think they aired
over i i'm not sure the exact number but
i think they are over 60 but we shot
over 300. shut up you shot 300 of those
yeah so fbi always there
what do you mean wasn't there somewhere
the fbi was there cause there were
secrets
oh i don't know
i don't know hodgman used to make a john
hodgeman who played the pc used to make
a joke about how when we'd go
that steve jobs would have people trail
us to make sure we didn't speak out of
turn about the company i mean obviously
it's not true right but maybe not
obviously it's not true maybe it is true
where did you hear that um i think i'm
set
we're gonna have to cut this
well because i sunset well when they
were only from an fbi guy on set
obviously um
i lured him to my trailer just to get no
there i think because i you and i
weren't doing one about the the ipad or
there was i just there was some
secret thing that like you guys could
touch that like
no one was allowed to know about and so
they had
people oh the i merkin
[Laughter]
no one else was allowed to touch that
but yeah
are you still friends with john i have
very close good friends and i did this
tv show together called married and he
like stole the whole show oh he's the
best he did it too we did two seasons
and he was the greatest he's so funny
he's so he's always so funny smart and
yeah and a lot of my stuff there
you know better than anyone when you're
on set how much waiting around there is
and how much of it is just like
man like so it's a social thing where
you like find the person that you
you know you did that movie in vancouver
and you're talking about baking with
somebody and that's what you take away
from it so a lot of it is like but there
is like a fine line between i'm learning
now i guess as i'm getting older just
doing this for longer like of like
managing
maybe because i'm just getting so tired
all the time like my energy level like i
like being on set always was social for
me like i was always on set like talking
and chatting and laughing i would eat
lunch every day with everybody and now
i'm kind of like learning like oh i need
to kind of like
like manage the day
a little bit more carefully and it could
also be the roles i'm playing too like
i'm not always playing like the goofy
funny like sidekick friends as much
anymore as i used to which in that
like those roles is always like more fun
to keep it fun keep it like buoyant yeah
yeah so it was always like always making
jokes and then when it was time to do
the scene it was like you're ready i was
like still in that mode and now i think
like oh i have to like eat lunch i like
eat lunch in my trailer just to like
stop talking for a little while like
just to like i say again same you know
what i mean and i feel like oh i used to
like want to go out every night after
work i used to like eat with everyone
and now i'm like i don't feel any
different except for i force myself to
do these little things now to like take
care of myself i i got a note that i've
been saying yeah too much during um so
you can't say yeah i can't say yeah but
i i so badly want to affirm what you're
saying because i feel the sound the same
thing yeah and i also feel kind of
shitty for not eating with the crew and
not eating with the oh yeah you know i
still have that well catholic uh always
but i think um there are some days where
i can do it in some days i just can't do
you remember that role that was that
that did spark that change a little bit
that that motivated you to
manage your energy i don't remember
exactly i know that like several years
ago i actually started working with an
acting coach
and it kind of made me take it all a
little bit more seriously and what
motivated that i was just feeling myself
like wanting to
take it a little bit more seriously and
because i was getting cast in roles that
were a little like i was like going more
and like a dramatic i was like playing
more dramatic roles which i hadn't
really done and like i don't know i just
want to be better like i want to be a
better actor so
until
you know i can go back to class it's
really helpful i mean we work out with
well i don't in theory one would work
out with the trainer to like get
i obviously do
clearly yeah um
who are we kidding i don't i jump up and
down on this trampoline by myself but
anyway um
it's super hard it's good for my
adrenals i think for the neighbors and
they really love it probably really fun
yeah
the so i thought like why not give this
a try and it's been really well that's
one of the things i i do love that about
acting is that you never feel
like you're done it's exciting to feel
like you're getting better well because
you can just keep playing like your
roles age with you and your
circumstances and like what you have to
offer and
it changes as you change that's why i
think it's so important for artists in
general to like travel and to have
hobbies and to go out in the world and
like when people become so sheltered
i had this like revelation about
starbucks the other day which made me
feel really happy i think i was just
like looking for an excuse to go to
starbucks because everyone in l.a is
like i go to this coffee shop and i go
to that coffee shop and blah blah and i
was like oh
i like starbucks it's right there it's
everywhere um and then i realized like
that i like starbucks because like
everyone goes to starbucks i guess
taking it back to like acting or being
an artist is like you can't play people
that you don't know or you don't see or
you don't like yeah and plus you can
steal so much from overheard
conversations
it's the best that's why i love people i
love in fact my brother and i were one
of my favorite things to do is sit
outside it's not starbucks but it's
joe's shout out to joe's on 23rd street
uh to sit outside a coffee shop and just
watch people yeah it's it's i know that
sounds like kind of whatever simple
thing to say but it's so no it's great
and that's what's so great about new
york and i think in l.a like we're all
in our cars all the time yeah so you're
i just find myself i live here but and
we're in la right now
i live here but i i get so much i get so
inspired by like when i'm in new york or
women in places where you take like
public transportation and
and where you can like be outside and
around people and it's so much more
interesting yeah now now do people you
are you must be
you're like famously recognizable in the
sense so don't you think of it didn't
you you wrote a book that was i touched
on that i don't know what you know me
from yeah
yeah it's in the title yeah i mean but
like it's like people are like you are
so familiar yeah how are you is it
usually like did we go to school
together it used to be but now it's it
now it's more mostly it's like you're an
actress what are you in mm-hmm
do they confuse you with other actresses
uh
one one person confuses me with one
other actress and
and it's my cleaning lady and
no matter how many times i tell her i'm
not this person
for the last 15 years you should start
confusing her with another cream
i'm like gloria i'm not her like she's
like no you are she doesn't know the
name of the person but she just thinks
i'm on this tv show and i'm like i'm not
on that tv show that's not me and she's
like okay she's like are you sure
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure you're like
she's like she's convinced she is
convinced do you not and i don't want to
pressure you to say but do you not want
to say because it'll sound like you
don't want to look like that person
yeah yeah yeah i said once i was um
i i
i was smoking a cigarette back when i
used to smoke which is gross that's
disgusting coffin nails what were you
thinking i was thinking i could be
anything i want even a smoker no you
can't
it was disgusting and and i was um
a girl was said can i get is really
drunk uh she said can i i can't take a
picture
she was i was taking a picture with her
and i had my i didn't want my cigarette
to be in the question of course because
it's gross and i was ashamed of myself
as i am even now talking about it um
so you get it it's cool it's really you
get how cool it is
and i had my so i put my arm behind her
with a cigarette and she goes as we're
taking the picture her friend is taking
like several
shots she goes oh my god i can't believe
you're like
you're like honest you're like a doctor
and you still smoke
what i was like what she goes yeah
that's [ __ ] up that you smell even
though you're a doctor on tv
and i said
who do you who do you think i'm
suggesting you know who you are
and i said i don't uh i i
do know who i i am i don't know you know
she said come on
mr scrubs
she thought i was donald faison no she
thought i was zac raff um and i and i
and i told that story because it's so
scintillating i told it at some comedy
show and and the next day there had
there was a writer for page six is that
new york times
the post and um it was on the gossip
thing uh page six and and it made it
sound like i was upset by it right that
i was offended by the comparison to zach
braff when in fact
yeah you know why not yeah
nothing wrong nothing wrong with zach
brad one time yeah i was in this oh what
do you got this was my fun well it's not
as good as yours but a man came up to me
at a furniture store and he was crying
and he told me that my performance in
magnolia changed his life
julian moore no no no no
melora walters walters yes so
yeah we're great in there
thank you
because he was clearly so emotional
about it and i regretted it i did
because
i
was like
this man is like so moved yeah he's
crying in a furniture store on a
saturday afternoon like i want to give
him this present
i want to give it to him but
what if that's very that's generous of
you and uh and also probably the least
awkward move in that situation because
you don't want to make him feel even no
did he feel
and did he just literally what i wish
most people would do is just said thank
you and like laugh yeah and it wouldn't
be funny if you ran into laura walters
he was like hey good to see you again
have you seen penn 15
no i heard it
you're
nothing is good until you see that show
and she's in it and i was like oh my
gosh there she is and i always think of
that story when i see her but that show
is amazing she's and she is incredible
yeah
yes do you know you must
start knowing these people just from the
audition circuit from the back
especially yeah yeah you kind of do you
have like the people and then you like
see the ones that become movie stars and
you're like oh
wait for me
i'll be there in a minute please get
pregnant
one less person in the waiting room
thinking about having a kid anytime soon
cause i'm gonna slip right into that
life could be a
what's your relationship with religion
like now it's that's a good question
because i don't know yeah because i
think for a while i was pretty committed
to saying like i don't believe in god i
don't believe in religion and it's all
[ __ ] and um i just don't know about
that anymore but i also
you meditate right oh yeah
yeah but that's not religion no no no
but there's there's an element of
spiritualism yes
and i think that like
i feel like that would help me out a lot
it's pretty great you don't do it no no
but i i i want to i i can't hook you up
if you want
but isn't it that thing you just kind of
do
yeah i can get you involved with um
transcendental meditation i would love
that it's a deep dive it's really great
oh yeah yeah you just lit up when you
yes you're talking about it the way you
get up when you're talking about john
cena's bottles and transcendental
meditation you
those are my two takeaways
by the way can you hook me up with both
of those things
i can definitely get you she has like
breasts they're like well they're like
muscles yeah
they're huge you should see his back is
bananas i'm like
back to transcendental meditation or tm
as we call it well what a pivot i know
it's great is back to traffic
it's so awesome yeah i've heard i have
it's really great and it's really
changed my life and i think
first of all i'm very jealous of the
people that are just like super
believers i actually have found in the
last couple years like i'm jealous i
wish i could feel that way about that i
would 100 be a born-again christian
like it seems awesome oh i'd be like a
snake handler i do the craziest [ __ ]
totally if i really could believe it i
don't but it seems so comforting you
know yes and also to just say well
that's you know what god wanted or that
was god's plan like all that stuff i'm
like
do you
you have kids i have step kids i have
two step kids okay and what are their
ages lucas is 19 and emily is 22. wow i
know they're like 100 and 103. oh my
gosh do they uh what did they think of
well their dad has been in the business
yeah so are they excited about when you
do
they don't seem to care if they do
they're better actors than i am because
they so they grew up in thousand oaks
and
i think um that is like just far enough
away uh it's just far enough away that
they're not really like
la la kids um and they there's there
certain things about what we do that
like they think like when i could throw
out the first pitch at the dodger game
like lucas just was like oh my god you
know and like every once in a while
there's like a movie premiere that they
want to go to was that nerve-wracking
yeah i was like freaking out i threw
like 200 pitches to prepare for that i
sat and like lucas is a pitcher himself
and so he like we put like a patio chair
and he's like aim for
like aim for the back of the chair and i
just threw pitches and pitches and
pitches and pitches
and then aj ellis was my catcher thank
god because i really loved him and i and
they were like just
aim for the la of his hat
um because you're always gonna throw it
down
and aim for that and then it's anyway
and i threw a strike whatever really i
did good for you oh god i would never be
able to deal with that pressure i will
say it was really terrifying but i did
stand in front of the mound
so a lot of people which everyone yeah
yeah the presidents do that when you
stand on the mound it's like a whole
other thing because of the height and
everything there's also a lot more
pressure i'm sure for like former
baseball player it's not like it's not
like you're delivering a line in a movie
and you're like you're stuck no one
expected me to yeah even come close yeah
they probably expected me to just like
drop the ball yeah yeah literally the
fact that it got to the glove that's
cool that's very exciting do you still
have that
drive for acting theater would you like
you did a play in 2012 uh theresa rebeck
play
my first and only broadway play was
teresa rebecc's play so far mine too
yeah pretty cool she's amazing and i
loved our play i love it so much still i
think it was so beautifully written and
had they ever talked about doing it
again elsewhere no i don't know i think
you know i don't like we closed a little
early i don't really totally understand
why
same same
this episode is called
um and
it was a drag but like it was awesome i
mean ours happened during hurricane
sandy which
wasn't great for many reasons but it was
just such an incredible experience and
all i ever want to do is theater now
because i think it's just the greatest
life
and there's that thing that you have
when you drive home from work when
you're shooting a movie or a tv show
where you're like oh that's what the
scene was about
exactly and then in the play you're like
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna try that tomorrow
night
when you get like you get hopefully so
many opportunities to
keep working on it keep exploring and by
the way if you don't want to like like
your [ __ ] is tight anyway so like you
can kind of do that too yeah if it's all
coast it's good for the kids to hear yes
they love hearing that yes um so do
directors i'm sure yeah of theater uh
so i heard judy greer likes to coast
whatever um these are gonna just be
quick
rapid fire or not necessarily but just
um okay what is your most commonly used
emoji
oh probably the blowing of the heart
of mine too same it seems to sum a lot
up it's great it can be and it can be i
use it often uh in a non-sexual way and
a non-romantic i never used it
romantically and i just realized it
might be romantic but i'm always like
but that's okay you're like john cena
i'm getting on a plane it turned out not
to be strep
see you soon
uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play holy
buckets
uh please no cursing oh
um
wow
as a professional athlete what sport
well if i said baseball
that would be cool because it would
really impress my stepson
um you'd be a pitcher be a pitcher but
um volleyball players have really
rocking bodies so that would be dope
yeah they do and um
so i guess maybe i would go with a
baseball player baseball with a
volleyball player's body yes um yeah you
have a volleyball player if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be oh a little stoned
well then popcorn
i like how my husband makes it he does
it in the pot on the stove
and it's really good yeah that's right
something really romantic about that i
want to add a blowing a kiss emoji to
that sentiment
it's really sweet how long have you guys
been
uh seven years seven and a half years
yeah and did you meet on a project
no blind date what yes no kidding like
blind blind like he's blind no i'm
kidding um
no
uh i'm friends with a writer on real
time with bill maher and and that guy my
friend matt gunn was like hey are you
single right now because my boss
is uh smart and funny and the chicks dig
him and i was like i'm single yeah set
me up but i didn't have and i don't
really have facebook so so dean that's
the husband's name he and i were like
talking on the phone and stuff and he
knew what i looked like but he was like
i feel bad that you don't know what i
look like so do you want me to like text
you a picture of me and i was like eh
don't bother because then it'll be weird
really i didn't know until i like opened
my front door oh my god you weren't you
weren't curious enough to i was curious
but i not enough i just was afraid like
what if it i don't know like you had
mentioned that looks
unless you're john cena looks aren't
that important to you
i i
i appreciate a good looking man for sure
but uh
i liked him so much talking on the phone
we talked on the phone for a really long
time like weeks leading up to our date
because of both of our schedules so i
was kind of like now i feel weird like
if i look at a picture of him
sorry next thank you
yeah actually i have to cancel and
reschedule never yeah so i just was like
i don't like dimples i mean i don't know
i was like god and then i had this like
moment like moments before he knocked on
the door where i was like i mean i'm
five nine that's kind of tall for a
woman what if he's like
i mean that's cool i've dated guys
shorter than me i don't mind that either
but i was like my plan was i was going
to open the door barefoot and i had a
pair of flats and a pair of like boots
with heels and it's like depending on
his height was what shoe i would put on
before we walked out the door but i was
trying on my boots with heels when he
knocked on the door and i was like you
know what [ __ ] it because
if this works out which i hope it does
then i'm not going to like not wear
heels for you yeah you want to be honest
you don't want to set a dishonest
precedent right so like here we are this
is who i am ah
that's what a great that's such a nice
story um
uh what is your favorite movie of all
time this is a tough one
um i would say tied for first is
moonstruck and tootsie oh
same for the second one you know i've
never now i it really makes me want to
see i love tootsies so much that it now
see the musical
um
i saw some of the stuff uh yeah i don't
know i've mixed feelings with the
musical because i love the movie so much
the movie's so sacred you know what i
would say and they're like i'm dressing
up to be a woman i would just not expect
don't think you're gonna see the movie
like look at it as its own thing i loved
it okay i loved it i think it's so fun i
think it's like really
it's worth it i was really nervous to
see it too because the movie is my
favorite but i thought it's kind of like
when i say to people about like if
you're eating like a vegetarian thing
like don't think it's gonna taste like
chicken that's true and and considering
all the parallels that we have
chances are i'll love it in fact i
should just take any recommendation of
yours from now on i should take all the
life advice uh if you had to live
somewhere else where would that be i'm
pretty obsessed with pittsburgh right
now really
yeah i really love pittsburgh again
they're shooting yeah i did a couple
movies there and i like really loved it
and i'm like i'm always looking at real
estate in pittsburgh can you do the
accent the yinzer
i don't know these guys over there i had
to do it in the last job i did a version
of it and i couldn't do i couldn't
commit to it because
i don't think anyone would understand if
i got it down not to say that i could
have but i had so little time to prepare
but it was fun to do do like a little
bit of the um i remember the phone call
was fun to say oh yeah those guys over
there got to make a phone call i didn't
notice because i was meeting local
people but you know everyone's like from
the movie so yeah but i just like loved
the town and it was just awesome it's
beautiful carson street
great like the the whole and anyway i
fell in love and then i became obsessed
with looking at real estate in
pittsburgh and then my husband's like
what am i going to do in pittsburgh i
was like oh right you i forgot i was
married to you
you and your career right
who's your favorite muppet
oh
well
i always like to miss piggy as a kid
but i haven't seen the muppets in a
really long time if you could have one
super power what would it be we usually
say i mean it used to be like
super hearing or or supervision uh see
through things or but maybe there's
another one that you'd want there's
always something i wish that when i met
someone i could see where they live
oh oh i'm always curious about
where people live oh interesting have
you ever had that experience where
you've gotten to know somebody then you
do see where they they live and it's
like oh i would never have thought this
yes yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
which is probably why i'm like i wonder
where like where do people live like
what do you like how do you live and
where do you live and what like what's
your space like on a daily basis if you
could be one age for the rest of your
life what would it be physically oh
physically
i mean 28. uh-huh
obviously uh if if you had to be a
non-human animal besides an ape
obviously um
what would it be like you know people
say like that's my spirit animal oh
no
i but what animal do you identify or
think like i'd be kind of cool to be it
seems really so hard to be an animal it
does so if it weren't such a struggle
and like survive to survive it seems
like turtles like could they have this
like safe shell they could be inside but
then they can also like walk around and
stuff
they're getting harder and harder to
leave the house right that's why those
jobs where you're sitting around in a
hotel room
beetle stones
beetles
beetles
beetles this is dark and i'd hate ending
on the dark things but but what would
you portion yes
what would you want your epitaph to read
do you want an epitaph
what do you want to have what is that
on the gravestone really if i get to
have one of those death things at the
academy awards yes
i just don't want it to be like an ugly
picture
like
the pictures you is like a female
werewolf or like yeah or like making a
goofy face or like so i'm like where
like i just like i just like want it to
be a pretty
like a picture where i look pretty yeah
so that people like oh my gosh
because
that's what i want that's funny it's the
first time i've i have an opposing
thought i i would like a kind of goofy
weird i feel like that would
hopefully sum me up better than some
sort of handsome uh yeah no i want the i
want the pretty one i want like the i
remember that
academy whoever is in charge i'm in the
academy so i think i do get to have my
picture okay well
fingers crossed
yeah
dropping this bomb on you funny morbid
john cena's body project john cena's
back um
kidding um is the show i do for showtime
with jim carrey and we're currently
shooting our second season so that'll be
on show time so many champions
oh well we'll have to have me back i
would love that we could do a whole
episode and i'm lucky that that you were
here because i've always wanted to
get to know you and i've always been
i've been such a fan for so long we were
actually the same person i know well
it's good which just makes me like even
more
in a very narcissistic way um thanks
thanks thanks for having me
[Music]
so
well well
what'd you think
uh me yeah you oh well um i don't know
who i thought you were talking to you're
looking right at me um
i think you're gonna say this but i felt
like i was talking to myself
in a good way
uh that's how arrogant i am i was like i
really enjoyed it yeah we're very like
she was amazing she's just like me
i really got along with her um at a
certain point there were things that she
said that would have been my answers to
and i think it was it all culminated in
but i didn't want to say anything
because it was getting a little bit like
in much with me agreeing with her and
like me too
um but when she said tootsie i couldn't
oh my god oh i'm gonna get to that okay
there's so many times it's like remember
you know when little kids
yeah on the playground or something
become best friends they're like same i
love that too we just become best
friends yeah it's like
this in fact this whole episode could be
called like samesies so many times
you're like oh my god same same yeah me
too and you know more superficial things
obviously like you were both
you don't both have to be in teresa
ryback please you were both in teresa
rebecca plays on broadway oh yeah uh
yeah i know weird you both have the same
favorite emoji you both had parents who
were his her mom's
none and our father oh my god in the
seminary um so all like you had a lot of
like superficial things in common yeah
but i would say
the the
the most important thing you had in
common that kind of connected you the
most was
you're both very
very curious people and
and she talked about loving going to
starbucks and people watching yeah oh my
gosh i'm talking about you know being an
actor and
needing to sort of experience the world
like absorb absorbing and like how
people talk and what they say to each
other and where people live she said her
superpower was she would love to know
where people live yes i would too yeah
same well but that's a very um that's a
thing about you i think and also about
her
that is uh unique in that you're both
very very curious people like i
yeah i mean i think she she would
probably like taking ubers for the same
reason i do i like having getting to
like be with strangers just for
limited and i like
it's like a confined um what's the word
it's like a set amount of time you know
not to say that you're they're the other
people aren't curious i mean plenty of
people are very curious no no we're very
unique
but i think there's something about that
level of curiosity that it uh feeds you
you know like like learning stuff and
picking up things from people kind of
nourishes you in a way that that i don't
see in most people well you know i think
i've gotten more like that over the last
couple of years and i think that has
coincided with my
i want to soak up more even if it means
like taking in people walking by in
front of joe's coffee or
talking to uber driver i i just want to
soak up more and i don't think that's
unique i think people i think that's um
a sign of getting older and awareness
well also we were just talking about
this in the way here actually that that
like the leaves changing and falling oh
yeah kind of reminds you of going back
to school and and with that comes this
kind of anxiety of oh my god of you know
when you're a kid you have to go to
school and you're kind of sad the
summer's over and but now the idea of
going back to school and learning stuff
is exciting it would be so exciting
and i think part of that is just getting
older and
wanting to soak things up now in a way
that you didn't want to back then oh
like watching a documentary when i was
in high school or like reading a book
like learning about history i
i could almost care less i liked those
things and like when i was forced to do
it i guess i would get into it but um
now the idea of doing those things is
is so exciting and when i see a school
bus i still get anxiety i'm like oh
thank you and i think oh i'm so grateful
i don't have to be on that
she's very charming and you know she
always plays those more quirky
characters in real life i think she's a
pretty quirky she's a person yeah but
and i think you know how i feel about
that personality type
quirky uh-huh is not my
brag it's not my bag typically
especially when people kind of push the
corki and they try to be quirky it's not
my favorite stuff yeah but uh she
strikes me as someone who's very
authentically yes quirky and and is very
comfortable with herself she has sort of
a flighty charm you know uh like she's a
little kind of head in the clouds like
uh yeah like you yeah wow it's not
always a good thing though i mean i i'm
not like charmed by myself i know that
certainly that part of me i don't find
charming like
or maybe i do i don't know i thought it
was funny that she left the catholic
church as a girl because
there were cuter boys in the protestant
church yes
that's where we don't align but even no
that's true but even funnier her parents
followed suit i know i they couldn't
have been that convicted about their
faith if they're like our daughter
thinks the boys
or i know that's what i was trying to
get at when i was like was it a dogma
thing was it right a doctrinal well you
were really trying to get at it because
at a certain point she goes are we going
to talk about my mom the whole time i
know i know and in her defense
no offense you were
really not letting it go for the first
10 minutes
about her mom's uh
failed
she said in the way i would say it and
we can talk about my mother the whole
time it's uh yeah she wasn't pissed off
no but when i heard that i was like i
know maybe she's pissed off me too
no no because i was sitting across from
her so i knew that she had a lightness
to her but i immediately felt bad
because
she was right like i was really what
you know it was like oprah you talked
about those years that that her mom was
the nunnery and our father was in the
seminary and you referred to them as
their [ __ ] years or she referred to
him as their [ __ ] she did i didn't do
that uh but you agreed and then you said
we were talking about her father's
[ __ ] years
and uh
you picture i never thought that i would
have
his name and the term [ __ ] years
connected into one sentence but it's an
awful
thought but then i thought it's gross to
picture but
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
that's why we're here
yeah he had his his [ __ ] proclivities
created us i guess yes
and those years age 17 to 24 is when
most people i think start
being free you do a lot of touching yeah
a lot of touching i know it shouldn't be
weird it it what's very strange is that
most of us will go our whole lives and
never know
the details about our
origin our very
reason
the reason we exist
which
i think to most people if most people
were given the option to go on a time
machine and witness their conception i
would suspect that the vast majority of
people would reject that that's a good
that's a good question you've asked me
that before i
i have a hard time with it like if if
you were given the pun intended
oh god
i wonder if it's such a strange thing
that we have that maybe there's an
evolutionary component to it that we
have this
instinctive repulsion to the idea of our
own creation there has to be because it
it um it prevents us from
i almost said hooking up with family
members but it prevents us from
indulging in
which would lead to genetic mutations
maybe she talks about her sweet spot
being three to seven on the call sheet i
totally agree and yeah well of course
same
and
it makes perfect sense that when when
you're not the lead of a movie it allows
you to have some free days and allows
you to explore and
see the city the best yeah and but also
in order to to want to do that it
requires checking your ego
which i think says a lot about her that
most people who have this ambition in
this industry
number one they want to be the star of
the movie but the fact that she's so
comfortable not being that i think
speaks to her uh
her ego right yeah and i think in the
long run it's better for a career that
that will last um because people don't
get burned out on
on somebody like if you do a bunch of
lead roles
people just get tired of watching
somebody do the aversion of the same
thing over and over unless you're like
the rock and then like people can't get
enough you do the same thing yeah um
actually a compliment to the rock it's
like please come on the show it's crazy
that people haven't gotten sick of you
yet the rock yeah i know but it it
speaks to his charm and like yeah
whatever
he had you know that thing well i think
that the rock has speaking of an
imposing incredible physical specimen
who knew that the two things that really
lit up judy greer would be john cena yes
and transcendental meditation those are
the two things that like
really drive her crazy yeah on the the
venn diagram of people who love those
two things there's a very very small
like crossover remember how flushed and
excited she got when she was describing
chauncey yes back muscles she was like
yes
she turned red
and now i'm forced to think because we
are so similar well would i if i
were attracted to men if i found men
sexually appealing would that be my
type would would i be well enthralled by
his muscles well i think
you should definitely do transcendental
meditation yes
to me that's a no-brainer if she's that
intuitive you should definitely try it i
can't believe i haven't seen but also if
you're going to i grieve if you
were going to dabble in men i think john
cena would be a good place to start
because if it's good
it should be good enough for you that's
true but but see john cena i would
actually be afraid he'd hurt me that's
what i'm saying yeah because he's so oh
oh yeah because he's so powerful like if
you were going to dabble in
homosexuality i would think that you
would dip your toe in
by
touching someone more like um like adam
who's like figure skating like alan
[ __ ] yeah alan cummings seems like a
he'd be a good kind of bridge
bridge to john cena
you know do you think you said alan
[ __ ] because
his last name is so sexual
i can't say no for sure but i don't
think so i think i would it was more
someone who
vaguely resembles you in terms of
body yeah yeah yeah he's kind of like
lithe and he's just got oh yeah well
is that how you think of yourself
no no
i'm thinking about live
no i it's uh i guess i'm alive yeah it's
funny just to describe yourself as live
hey let's read a letter okay yes uh
oh i'm excited for this one because uh
you have i've heard
i've heard it's really good it's a funny
letter and i haven't read it i'm excited
to read it for the first time
this is from rachel the subject is judy
greer endorses this email and a nerdy
nerd emoji
hello justin and christian at the end of
your last episode justin said quote my
spanish is so limited that every year i
get inspired to learn it again and um i
don't
my immediate thought was i can teach him
before that thought could turn into a
pipe dream i reached out to my current
student to ask her if she would mind it
my name dropping to provide you with a
reference as luck would have it she told
me she was just on your podcast
what and that i should certainly share
this information with you
judy greer is who i am referring to
that's weird
she and her husband two of the best
humans on the planet have been taking
online spanish classes with me for the
past few months and it has been the
highlight of my week if you are
interested please hit her up for a
reference regardless i truly hope that
someday soon you
in quotes
which means
cockatoo bullets
so that you can expand your world
through spanish that's really
now if you heard jonah the episode of
the jonah hill a couple weeks ago
that will mean something to you it won't
mean as much as it means to us because
we've been saying cockatin pull it for
going on like a couple decades now but
uh that is really funny oh it goes on
sorry it's not over uh now a little blip
about life is short your podcast is the
audio version of a norman rockwell
painting oh my god
uh it's so nice every episode sparks
what not picasso
it's not that abstract it's just as good
but now that i'm sorry every episode
sparks nostalgia and joy listening into
conversations much like the ones i've
shared with family and friends over the
years it's so nice it can be hard to
seek out that level of intimacy as life
gets crowded with responsibilities but
damn if it isn't one of your basic our
basic needs that being said i applaud
you for providing authentic interactions
with which span the range of human
emotions and experiences
that's so nice i'm sorry i stumbled over
that thank you and keep up the good work
you guys rachel d
uh so nice so nice and you were
uncomfortable with that level compliment
so you like
just blabbed it out maybe maybe
subconsciously i definitely said it
poorly because i yeah because you
couldn't read that out loud about
yourself in an articulate way it is so
kind of too flattering and anyway i
think it's safe to say that norman
rockwell uh was a better painter
than
this is a podcast but it's an extremely
flattering comparison and uh and i do
think you should take her up on that
offer
absolutely learn spanish well it's
something you've been talking about for
a long time you know for um a long time
and uh
and i think you should do it
if it's good enough for judy greer
that's right you should learn spanish
and transcendental meditation
and maybe fool around with john cena
those are my takeaways for uh what you
should be doing with your life
yeah yeah so if you guys want to write
in with
any advice for justin or anything you
want to write about really but how you
make the most out of life how i might
come into contact with john cena yes uh
you could write into us at life is short
at wondering.com and armatia
armatia iyala a
um
thank you rachel yeah rachel there's a
facebook group which by the way we
should shout out because it's really
nice it's a life is short it's a fan pub
and
they call themselves shorty shorties
which i think yeah
and uh awesome it was started by
haley gonzalez uh so shout out to shout
out and uh it's it's a small group but
it's growing in size numbers so if you
guys are on facebook check it out yeah
life is short fan club thanks to
everyone all the shorties all the
shorties yeah i'm a shorty too i signed
up for michael oh you did for the group
i'm not on facebook otherwise i would
too be a shorty and thanks to judy for
being um
justin's female doppelganger for
confirming the things that i like about
myself and the things that i
want to uh
get better at
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
uh this has been life to short hosted by
me justin long
male judy greer
produced by christian long and megan
monica of course how are you getting
worse at this our senior producers
michelle miesh lans audio engineer is
marcelino viapando
executive producers are ernan lopez and
marshall louis for wondering thanks for
listening
[Music]
also if you just met superman he's got
to be the most famous guy in the world
right like in definitely in smallville
so you'd be like yeah holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] as soon as someone else would come
back you'd be like you have
this is crazy we just met zuma and you
would recount it to such detail that
you'd be like
wait you
in fact
i know this is true
something like you look have you ever
gotten this before you kind of look like
superman
like a little like
like you you look you're the similar
hype you're the same exact character
just kind of similar face not like even
just like a little bit you like you just
want to talk you have like a similar um
sounding boys too and you it's crazy
move your mouth in a similar way how did
they get away with that in the comic
book how dumb were people then it's
crazy it's crazy i mean it's nice you
know what it is
to your point earlier nerd
in the comic book if you don't see it
play out the nerd character you could
imagine to be
so different from the cool suit um
superman character
that in your mind in your imagination it
might be easier to see how different
they are whereas in this
there's only so much one actor can do
right that's true like actually
you